you don't they squeeze aujourd'hui on se
trouve si on met les hommes forts rica
ou pas la croix bleue grenouille en
français c'est une sorte de gta on
contrôle une grenouille voilà dans un
monde ouvert c'est absolument
fantastique aux distributeurs j'adore
distributeurs d'ailleurs récemment je me
suis fait on s'en fout un distributeur
qui vaut une hache et un est un poisson
et c'est tellement cruel quoi la vie de
ce poisson est tellement nulle dans un
[ __ ] distributeurs allez on s'en va
bienvenue à froch city vous êtes ici
dans la ville des grenouilles elle
sourit ce traitement nombreuses et
vivent paisiblement jusqu'à ce que on
arrive deux d'or on commence par faire
un petit poupon a à g 8 ans et demi ça
m'a changé de tenue en plus sa botte le
cul quand journée toilettes les
histoires des valeurs ont bien au
pouvoir jouer aux échecs là bas c'est
beau ça à la musique c'est chiant c'est
celle au stop stop où abondent pour qu
est-ce qu on peut vraiment jouer aussi
du fait qu attention révéler aux os ça
j'adore ce genre de jeu attention il
vous plaît tu es belle avec la musique
c'est un peu du leur vin qui sèmerait un
toboggan ta ta ta ta ta ta de sa cuisse
même passé lors de [ __ ] j'suis un peu
plus ou lavage ou un bateau qu'on
appelle ça un zodiac trouvera des
cultures avec squeeze 100% déjà en
france ah ben ça mais bon on a une odeur
de vanille pihouet l arnaque ou
rediffusés à temps c'est impossible ça
marche il croit pas une seconde
voilà ce que j'avais dit voilà parce
qu'à prendre la tête on peut rien faire
parce que c'est comme ça en vol le 22 et
pis au bon dieu je vais aller là où on
attendait on va tenter on va tenter
voilà la maniabilité thaçi est mon gars
incroyable non la vidéo de la non
maturité ça se passe sur la chaîne de
squeeze aujourd'hui attention le temps
de paix se donne 3 2 à o mais le saut
pour y attends je peux juste rester là
sur ce sur ce lampadaire je veux voir
mes potes les grenouilles savent à quoi
m ont brouillé par nathalie la taille et
voilà il est décédé c'était presque
aussi stylée que la mode d'ordre
avengers
ils partent s'en foutent quoi s'est
amusé c'est la distraie j'aime beaucoup
distraire les gens gratuitement dans la
rue commence à 10h les spectacles de rue
comme actuellement
c'est drôle on va passer par là qu est
ce qu a lyon il ya une caméra on va
faire des podcasts de grenouilles sais
pas si vous avez remarqué mais dans les
voilà abonnez vous ici caméra fraude
pour fraude civile
je suis dans cette fameuse ville propre
et de grenouilles les gens me regardent
bizarrement comme lui par exemple on me
dit vous voyez la caméra écoutez santé
sont horribles c'est drôle 1 3 4 6 8 et
howie attendez attendez prend le
deuxième promotion prend deuxième alors
là on regarde ndiaye de châteaux
gonflables louga est ce qu'on fait au
concombre est ko
comment breaker la beauté du geste
regardez elle vole délicatement
maintenant ici caméra fera pour franck
steevy regarder dans ces bidons se
trouvent des insectes il faut ce pouvoir
ce pouvoir et trois de ses quatre ils
ont mis à notre disposition un terrain
de basket
on n'a pas les beatles ac s'est musclé
pour faire du basket
aura-t-on de regarder ce beau ce [ __ ]
j'ai tellement non c'est non à mon avis
ça balance pas assez loin au karément
paul quoi qu'est ce que c'est que ça est
ce que c'est une sorte de da de statut
d'art moderne avec des contenaires pour
signifier finalement la société de
consommation tous ses achats regroupés
dans des conteneurs sur les ports prêts
à atterrir dans les loyers les français
en rêvent de plaisanterie ici caméra
frob pour franck tivit jeu fait
poursuivre pas connu la jirs perd un
petit tunnel dans lequel me cacher on
est maintenant à l'abri
pas tellement court on aime porter porté
porté des coups à oui celle ci elle
s'ouvre mais quelle est cette musique
entraînante et dos messieurs
mais serait ce une discothèque pour gods
bel et bien traversé en tout cas
absolument personne
on la leffe ps moyens pour ça qu'il dit
lol ça le fait rêver je me dire je veux
des fps s'il vous plaît on tue une ak-47
mais qu'est ce que ça fait non violent
mon dieu attends je me fatiguais par un
gang là qu'elle est n'est pas parce que
cette scène est totalement ridicule et
improbable maintenant [ __ ] insalubrité
les femmes mais quoiqu'il s'accrochant
foulard mais qu'est ce que c'est que ses
grands dieux qu'ils mangent du porc
secrètement jeu qui tape ce jeu qui tape
se porte
ceci est une perquisition de la france
glisse voilà mélange de deux projets de
police avaient compris je rame comme un
gros porc [ __ ] ça thomert puisque je
suis sur un gros porc de mieux en mieux
ses jeux de mots violents sur des vidéos
c'est incroyable et yonhap bon par
contre cette saine doit vraiment prendre
fin un jour s'il totalement ridicule non
mais là je suis à 5 ap astic
c'est plus possible ça suffit plus tard
et violet mois à violer moi moi je bois
je m'en vais finalement mois qu'on nous
y mais qu'est ce que c'est que ça on
passe ici presque je m'éjecte alors j'ai
tenté le savez avec la projection
peut-être que non c'est très stressant
de marche avec celles du new gm sont
deux claques et des fesses à chaque
seconde en fait écouter non c'est
bizarre c'est c'était glauque je sais
pas ce qu'ils enregistreront faire ce
week-end je me suis je préfère pas
savoir de vidéo finalement attendait là
bas ça sent les trucs cachés là entre
les du mob discrètement aulas attend ça
va passer ou par non non au podium on
devrait voiture s'envole la voiture
s'envole je sors je sors de là c'est
trop pour moi
jeu laissez moi sortir oyez d'arbalète
j'ai vu leur maladie et arbalète mais
n'avait pas dans l'immeuble juste là en
dessous aux mondiaux ans quitte pas mais
c'est ça qu'on veut
oui c'est le lendemain que les
américains un petit peu en difficulté
l'utilisent pour se déplacer et ben il
est aussi ridicule que ce que je pensais
ça va à deux kilomètres heure aux atomes
facebook style et quoi qu à bâbord et
s'il ya moyen de faire un petit stade
gazonné on va tenter tant sur le slide o
latorre ya un truc ici caméra fraude
pour fraude civile on met des t-shirts
avec des mouches dessus pour nous donner
envie et auprès de nouri sabah souffle
base de pois chiches
ok on y est mais non mais pas à me force
pas à rire moi
regardez hop on passe d'un côté à
l'autre comme ceux ci et on s'amuse
beaucoup voilà un mois que j'ai trouvé
le véhicule le cacher c'est avec ça
qu'on drague de la grenouille c'est ça
faudrait jeter non mais c'est quoi ce
foutu oui voilà au plat et la rampe la
non lâche ma voiture
au dessus un terrain de foot comment
gagner un match de foot a foncé avec sa
petite voiture dans le ballon et marquer
quand cet état a regardé ce pont vers 5h
ce nouveau jeu reconnaissait à quatre
chevaux attendait a tonné me semble que
cette fois elle fait un peu de bruit
quand même c'est une bruel patrick bruel
c'est de mieux en mieux plus tard
méthode moines oscar à la fois légère et
très c'est promis tous leurs traces
fabrique un dos car la batterie on est
donc sur le toit du parquet il ya un
petit repos line pour aller là-bas pas
un tremplin aux et là il faudra t il sur
le trampoline qui est juste là au nom
laisser ça là bas dans l'herbe c'est un
titan mondiaux défendons-nous et casar
s'est levé qui voit la techno de la taxe
décidée dans tous les jeux c'est génial
donc là juste en dessous il ya le fameux
contenait renouer avec le tremplin pour
aller au delà du mur
mon dieu mais c'est hyper dangereux y'a
pas moyen d'aller sur le trampoline
directement là comme ça avec la voiture
le dépasse à jouer aux jeux mondiaux gao
puis envoyé technique beaucoup plus sain
pour franchir ce mur au paba là-bas la
pop alors ils ont bloqué je voulais
faire un ton complètement d'hôpitaux
mais dont je rentre dans ma ferrari tu
es dans ta jalousie non plus
sérieusement je rentre dans ma voiture
déjà qu'à bosser avant même que je
conduise on va tanguer une salle de gym
en la lame est vraiment le cercle prg
attendu l'on va pousser un petit peu la
foule cela tu sais le plus musclé et tu
pas un super u direct on me dit que j'ai
leur prouver ma virilité à tout jamais
au plat et de hors jeu lattaque le
défaut ce jeu le meilleur du ried
hop là je suis la vase et on vous a vu
ça mais quelle mouche de folie et toi on
prend on voit la noyer on va dans la
piscine du rapt
vim wen voit les gens c'est à dire 30
cette notion se mêle une fois j'espère
que ça vous a plu c'est le cas n'hésitez
pas mais les vidéos comme d'habitude
c'était donc j'étais à 5 sur pc il vient
de sortir j'espère si vous appelez ça
tombe très bien toutes prochaines vidéos
versa regarder sur tout le monde
pis